to those who attended marker shards
reading last night you are already aware
of our guests accomplishments and
accolades you know that he is an
award-winning short story writer a
best-selling novelist a journalist
published in the New York Times
Harper's and vogue a former
correspondent for the BBC he is a
screenwriter and producer who has
contributed to acclaimed television
shows on CBS AMC and Fox he is a teacher
who has generously sought to cultivate
talent in others as a visiting writer in
residence at UC Irvine the University of
Mississippi and the University of South
swanee among other institutions he has
been the recipient of more honors than
will fit in a brief introduction and
although marker shards literary
accomplishments are sufficient cause for
our attention although he has been
called the heir apparent to Mark Twain
Flannery O'Connor and William Faulkner
he would merit our attention even
without such critical acclaim
mr. Rashard is a bold writer wide awake
to the world whose mastery of the
written word dignifies the story and
it's telling as an essential piece of
what it means to be human
whose candor and humility entrace
readers in a world that ultimately
brings them to a deeper understanding of
their own tonight's reading is a
particular blessing because we are
privileged to hear mark Rashard tell his
own story a story that cultivates in us
the capacity to discern the textures of
life in its richness and the courage to
look with grace at the world and not
avert our eyes please join me in
welcoming mark Rashard
thank you that was really really great
thank you and thank you again John for
having me the Hillsdale English
department it's it's great to be back
here and I've always I feel churchy
though being here
so feeling churchy I'm gonna read sort
of a churchy section of this book I
debated all afternoon as you as writers
were kind of neurotic I wanted to read
the first section of the book which ends
and you know me showing a little bit of
possible tiniest bit of talent and
second grade too right because I was
able to write one good sentence and the
mother the mother my mother saying no he
just wants to be the guy that picks up
trash with the stick with the nail on
the end of it which I still kind of want
to do because I thought that was a
really good job to have if you could
just walk around the park all day at
Otterbein Park in New Orleans around a
monkey house this book will talk if I
want to get into it because I don't want
to go long and and I also thought the
first section is too long to read I
don't want to go along but I do want to
give it a little bit of a preface the
book begins with a suggestion that is
echoed in the beginning of the piece
that I'm going to read right now the
book begins with mmm
say you have a special child which in
the south means one between Downes and
dyslexic so that's how the book begins
there's a weird point of views shift the
book is generally told a second person
which we can talk about which is really
I think there's been a lot of papers
written about this that I can't
understand and then it makes this is
almost like a third person second person
specific entrance and I don't I'm just
mimicking things I've read and then it
really gets earnestly into second person
with the the piece that I'm going to
read right now and I was conscious of
staying within the confines
The Voice I've chosen but the second
section the first section is about me
not really showing much promise in any
promise I had being diminished by myself
and then the second section is about
about being a writer the Sexson second
section is more when I was growing up
with bad hips going to Richmond Virginia
to the Children's Charity Hospital there
we didn't have a lot of money and going
to Richmond meant something bad was
going to happen to you so going to
Richmond was with something you tried to
avoid so at the end it's about when the
narrator is talking about going to
Richmond we know that that's that has
meaning that is fraught after I read
this this section I'd like to read one
little piece it's about three pages
about a character I call the preacher
excuse me the preacher was the Baptist
minister who lived across the street
from me who had four sons I was kind of
in the middle of their ages so I grew up
at their house and he was a very
progressive Baptist minister in a very
conservative southern South Virginia
racially divided town he was way ahead
of his time and I just feel like he's
dead now I'd like to give him a
shout-out so I'm gonna read this section
I'm gonna read that and then we'll be
done refreshments upstairs but we can
talk afterwards as well too I like to
talk if you've been with me these last
couple of days you know I don't mind
sitting down and talking so if you're
around and want to talk afterwards we
can do that too and if you have other
places to be can just get up I'm not it
doesn't hurt my feelings so here's the
second incantation of say you are the
child say you are the special child say
one reason you're special is because
there is something wrong with your legs
you cannot run your legs will not move
fast enough when you try to run your
hips click and pop when you have to run
a race like at the going-away party at a
doctor's house in the old town
when everyone was running toward the
doctor's house that would burn
completely to the ground the next year
you per trend pretend to trip and fall
and not finish the race you avoid foot
races you avoid running at all when
something bad happens and everyone else
runs away rocks thrown through
greenhouse clasps loose spikes thrown at
passing caboose windows fishing boats
untethered along a riverbank you know
you will have to face whoever is coming
at you in their anger you learn you must
never get caught in the Newtown the
teachers don't say you are special as
the teachers did in the old town these
the words slow and you are slow but they
also say you are slow when you're
sitting at your desk
unable to color the state bird you can't
get the red crayon to work on the
Cardinal in a way that makes the teacher
happy
your father has said to be careful about
signing your name to anything so you
don't put your name on your homework
a suspicious teacher has said that if
your parents are really from Louisiana
you must be able to speak French oui you
say you try to speak with a French
accent you still try to spend your
Confederate money you still wear your
father's army helmet to school no one
can understand what you're saying and
the big boys from out in the county want
to fight you in line to the cafeteria
they come up behind you and flip off
your helmet and you have to fight them
almost every day the fighting finally
stops when you break a boy's hand when
your mother finds out she cries because
she is afraid the boy is the son of a
new friend of hers you get the feeling
it was selfish of you to break the boy's
hand a good afternoon in the new town is
when the school is struck twice by
lightning everyone else starts crying
when the lightning strikes the swingset
first you stand at the window it's
raining and thundering and the lightning
strikes the roof but the Sun is also
shining and you heard from your father's
mother that
rains and the sun is shining that means
the devil is beating his wife as the big
boys from the county and all the girls
cry for their mommies and the teacher is
shouting for everyone to get into the
cloakroom you clap and laugh and shout
the devil is beating his wife the devil
is beating his wife the children and the
teacher are afraid of your loud laughter
and you can tell them by their looks as
they crowd into the cloakroom as you
stand by the open window getting soaked
by the windblown rain the special child
one morning you do not have to go to
school your father does not put on his
forest clothes the khaki shirt denim
jeans snake pistol long sheath knife the
boots with wire laces that won't burn in
case he gets caught in a forest fire and
has to make a run for it he puts on a
coat and tie and you get in the car with
him he drives you to Richmond through
swamps low woodlands fields turned over
for peanuts and corn neither of you
speaks there's just the tires on the
corduroy road and his Flying Tiger class
ring clicking clicking the window
when he lifts his cigarette ash to the
roll down crack at the top you always
keep an eye out for the tiger you never
know when it may fly across your face
your father turns the gray sedan into a
long driveway between green lawns to a
place it looks like a museum your father
signs you in and you take an elevator
upstairs the place smells like linoleum
wax and medicine and shitty diapers
you and your father sit on folding
chairs in a long dark hallway with other
fathers and mothers and what an odd boy
who lives in the place later calls sin
spawn children with withered legs legs
of different lengths bent up legs legs
and steel and leather braces hobbling
kids crying and carrying the smell of
places where people who live who tote
water and buckets from a well and go to
the bathroom and shed
back a lot of the people waiting have
long greasy hair that needs cutting you
can tell some are missing teeth when
they talk and smoke and spit in the
metal trash can by the exam room door a
woman in a white uniform comes out with
a clipboard and hands it to your father
you read the top of the paper and you
understand why you are special when you
read crippled Children's Hospital the
doctor has seen your x-rays he twists
your legs and makes your hips crack and
pop on the white paper table the doctor
doesn't answer your father's questions
the doctor says he will try nails in
your hip your father wants to know if
the doctor will put the nails in your
hips himself the doctor doesn't answer
your father
he says nails are the best remedy your
father asked if there is any other
remedy and he says that in a way that
makes him sound like a smartass the
doctor stares that your father insists
loudly with or without the nails your
son will probably be in a wheelchair by
the time he's 30 anyway to cheer you up
your father takes you to the Hollywood
cemetery where some of your heroes are
buried President Jefferson Davis
major-generals Jeb steward and George
Pickett you and your friends have spent
many afternoons playing Pickett's Charge
in the group in the park across from the
Episcopal Church running into withering
Cannon and musket fire and because of
your legs you are always the first
casualty as the minie balls rip into
your arms and throat falling dying in
the grass
sometimes crawling beneath the azalea
bushes were robert e lee sits astride
his iron gray horse traveler him saying
down sadly i'm sorry i'm sorry it was
all my fault after you visit the grave
of the doctor who amputated stonewall
jackson's arm intended to lee's heart
attack on the eve of gettysburg you go
see the big black iron
that guards a little girl's grave by the
time you get to the grave of Jefferson
Davis's five-year-old son Joe Davis
you're ready to go home at the hospital
they strip you naked and scrub you with
tar smelling the lousing soap and a deep
sink there an old tiled room full of
dreams even though you had a bath that
morning before leaving home with your
family a nurse takes the green cardboard
suitcase your mother had packed for you
that morning and says she'll deliver it
to your father in the reception office
it's the green cardboard suitcase you
used to carry your cat in here are your
new clothes nice and clean with somebody
else's name in the warned waistband of
the donated shorts and then the collars
of the two old summer camp shirts one of
the shirts is a good one yellow red and
white mattress and in the coming months
you will trade for it back when it goes
through the laundry and is given to
someone else here is the t-shirt to
sleep in here is a fresh sheet for your
bed once a week put the top sheet on the
bottom the fresh sheet on top and here
is your bed on the Sun porch the boys
ward is crowded in summer your bed looks
out over the rigging and masts the bars
and chains of the playground swing sets
that night it will all look like
shipwrecks in the gray streetlight when
you turn away from the crying around you
and stare out through the metal safety
rails of your bed your mother sat in
your father's car in the parking lot
earlier that afternoon nursing your baby
sister because your mother's luck has
changed she's had a baby and she's going
to hell she and another lady went into
the little Catholic Church to put fresh
flowers on the altar one Saturday
afternoon and the priest came out of
sacristy with a rope belt and scotch on
his breath women in culottes defiling
the altar [ __ ] the priest swung the
rope belt and in her weekly call to her
own mother later in losing
your mother says she has left the church
were good then you are going to hell her
mother tells her goodbye on the
extension you hear someone take it
breath quickly after your grandmother
says this and you don't know if it's
your mother or the long-distance
operator who sometimes listen ends and
lives down their street in a sorrow
filled house with her three children who
used to be four children until one
drowned and the frozen pond behind the
cemetery like a lot of people seem to do
including mrs. Richardson from one
Street over from your Sun porch bed that
afternoon you saw your father returns to
the car with your green suitcase and
tell your mother something and it seems
she didn't understand but later he could
tell she was crying as she nurses your
little sister your father walks over to
the empty playground where no one is
allowed because it is not playtime and
he sits in one of the swings and you
watch him change smoke for a while until
he sees your mother burping his sister
and he looks at his watch a nervous boy
comes up to you and says some kid died
that morning and you figure out you got
the dead kids bed when you look out next
your father is gone there's an empty
swing set swinging and there's an empty
swing swing and the swing set in the
morning you go out to the playground
with all the other crippled children and
you find the swing where your father sat
the smoked tobacco and the cigarette
butts ground into the ashy dust and the
next days they draw your blood and take
your temperature the x-ray used some
mourn forgets you in a hallway until
suppertime they make you walk naked in
front of an auditorium of young student
doctors and nurses from a college walk
run stop stand on one leg hop run some
more also in the audience or boys and
girls your age they see how you can't
run naked how you can't even hop naked
how you can barely walk naked they laugh
at first until they realize in a few
minutes a nurse will remove
their gowns and make them jump run walk
and hobble naked to one day after lunch
instead of a nap a nurse takes you and
her purse out in the front of the
hospital to wait for a taxi cab the taxi
cab takes the two of you to a laboratory
downtown by the way the nurse pets your
head you know this is going to be bad
they give you a shot that makes you
drowsy and begin to dream but you don't
fall all the way asleep while you were
drowsy and beginning to dream they lay
you on your side and push long needles
into your spine somebody in your dream
is screaming it's you later in the taxi
cab back to the hospital the nurse holds
you in her arms like a backseat Pieta
the sunlight burns your eyes and the
telephone wires hang and loop hang and
loop in the hospital auditorium you had
noticed these words painted in large
letters over the stage suffer the little
children to come unto me who said that
you asked the nurse who took you to the
laboratory
the nurse who sometimes sneaks coke into
your mettle spell cup when everybody
else gets tap water nurse well phone
Jesus Jesus Christ she says what kind of
jerk would want little children to
suffer you wonder nurse Wilfong says
you're constipated they keep track of
everyone's bowel movements in a ledger
you didn't know you had to report a
bowel movement while you were still
walking around if they hadn't sent you
upstairs yet to let the young doctors
practice taking you apart and nailing
you back together
nurse wolf farm wants you to drink
chalky stool softener while you want to
talk about what a jerk Jesus must be if
that's what he said about children and
suffering it's creepy like the older boy
is going around saying a kid down in
North Carolina went into a department
store bathroom and some man cut his
penis off with a pocketknife the older
boys say it was in the newspaper the
hospital is crowded with children from
Appalachia who
knees that have to be cut up and legs
that have to be sawed off they're a
pretty happy bunch they love the food so
much you give them yours and you don't
heat it anyway the first night you went
into the lunch table room there was a
black kid sneezing snot into his plate
of food right before the blessing the
woman who ran the lunch table made
everyone slide down one plate so you
could squeeze in and you got the plate
with the droplets of snot on the realm
the rest of the snot having disappeared
into the stewed tomatoes and cabbage and
boiled meat the Appalachian kids start
eating off your plate as soon as it's
sat down in front of you one of the
Appalachian kids had been sent home with
a long cast on his leg and when he comes
back and they cut off the cast they find
bugs have nested in there the black kid
who blew snot all over your food is on a
respirator now you lie awake and watch
the stop light change out on Brook Road
and wonder if there was enough of
something in that one spoonful of stewed
tomatoes you choke down so that you'll
start coughing of bloody snot yourself
the ward overflows with deformity and
crying kids at night it's been two weeks
maybe they've forgotten about you then
one night they get you the night nurse
in the night porter jerk and will your
bed into the prison spotlight of the
night nurses desk lap so she can better
see to tie no breakfast signs to your
bed rails the young doctors will be
waiting upstairs for you in the morning
they'll make Ben or Howard or one of the
other black orderlies come down and
fetch you you hope you will come back
alive because everyone knows even the
little boys on the other end of the ward
that not everybody comes back from
upstairs sometimes boys end up on a
gurney covered in bloody sheets and
tossed off scrubs down in the basement
waiting for a station wagon from the
state to fetch you Big Mike says Big
Mike has burns over 90% of his body and
carries a single condom in an otherwise
empty
he knows things you begin to pray to God
directly
forget the creepy men's room Christ who
wants you to suffer and you hope
somebody has called your parents because
sometimes they forget to do that too
no one tells you you wake up in a body
cast so it is a surprise when you wake
up and you are in a cast that reaches
from under your arms and goes down to
your knee on one side and down to your
toes on the other you vomit a lot coming
out of the anesthesia as harelip kids
bang around under your bed playing
cowboys you remember trying to push
yourself out of the cast like an insect
molting its shell and only the searing
burn of the stretching of freshly fresh
stitchery covering the hammered in nails
around one hip makes you stop the heat
of the place in the day and the fear of
cockroaches that might crawl down into
your cast at night make it hard to sleep
the nurses put you out on a smaller Sun
porch that has some books that aren't
worth reading
mostly school books written before World
War two for a while there are two
Jerry's one Jerry is the guy who is
called the human skeleton his clothes
look like scarecrow rags he ranges
around on his bed waiting for someone to
come to close so he can bite the person
with his large buck teeth he has one
large testicle that sways back and forth
when he crouches at the foot of his bed
chomping at the air later when you are
in a wheelchair and you can sit beside
his bed and feed him crayons he lets you
pet his head like a dog and he Pat's
your arm and howls the other Jerry is
from Appalachia
he has calm even features and a trusting
smile and eyes of a schoolbook pioneer
standing on a mountaintop leading a
wagon train into a lush green valley
beyond already the doctors have taken
off one of his legs in the daytime it
does
seemed to bother him too much but at
night as you watch for roaches crawling
along your bed rail so he can flick them
off you see Jerry in silhouette against
the brook road streetlight and you can
see him stare down at the place where
his leg used to be you pretend you are
asleep
Jerry throws himself back onto his
pillow and Jerry cries and you know he
is trying not to you want to tell him
that it's all right that everyone here
cries at night here is a miracle you
find a game board in a box of chess
pieces none missing you teach Jerry to
play chess at nap time when all must be
quiet
Jerry sets up the board on a small table
beside his bed he touches each of your
pieces with just the tip of a finger
waiting to see if that is a piece you
want to move you nod your head he moves
the piece you clear your throat for the
number of spaces pointing a finger to
adjust direction when Jerry moves his
pieces you see he's playing a cautious
defensive game castling confounds him
only when he almost makes the most fatal
errors do you snap your fingers and he
looks up to see you tapping your temple
telling him think you don't want to keep
beating him he knows this and he tries
harder just when you were about to quit
one afternoon he puts you in check and
if he weren't missing a leg and you
weren't flat on your back in a body cast
you'd both get up and shake hands
instead the two of you clap without
making a sound because it is nap time
and all must be quiet on Sunday mornings
Jerry's family comes down from the
mountains somewhere near Cumberland Gap
they leave their houses in the dark and
drive across the state just to be with
Jerry for a few hours they stand there
and hold on to his clothes as if he
might float away
Jerry's family doesn't bring him
anything to eat and you know it is
because they don't have anything to
bring his parents
look at Gerry in his face and hold on to
his clothes and Gerry looks down at the
leg that he has left and there you are
across the way with grease all over your
fingers eating a fried chicken box lunch
your parents have brought knowing
Gerry's family is all hungry and will
drive back across the state without
stopping
Your Mother has also brought you a toy
with the fried chicken box lunch a blue
plastic plate and a stick
the idea is to spin the plate on the end
of the stick the first time you try to
spend the blue plastic plate on the end
of the stick it flies off and hits
Gerry's father on the back Gerry's
father picks up the blue plastic plate
and kindly passes it back to your mother
and she smiles and hands it to you and
you are ashamed
sundae's bring the young seminarians the
practice preachers murmuring down the
hallway doing God's work visiting the
sick and their hush puppies shoes all
smiles until they smell you they can't
control you around the piano wheeled out
of a classroom they can't make you love
Jesus fail to threaten you with the
Prophet Elisha who called down the
she-bears to rip the 42 little mocking
children to shreds you all laughing at
the violent story was spitting hair lips
and cleft palates and brandishing canes
and crutches nudging the seminaries into
the clutches of the human skeleton and
brain-damaged dentists who will bite and
strangle them the practice preachers
looking as all visitors ultimately do
for a nurse and a quick exit but the men
from the barber college who come to cut
your hair clicking down the hall and
polished loafers laughing and goofing
their smiles steadfast as they round the
corner and smell you see you mangy
mongrels with overgrown bowl cuts from
the hills crew cuts from the Piedmont
gone to seed post-surgery mattad twists
of bet
hair pressed against pillows 24 hours a
day
the barbers come whistling with jokes
and songs and gum and they touch you
they cradle your heads and their hands
as they trim you hold you in their arms
so you can safely lean over the edge of
your bed and your body cast as they open
your faces with their scissors telling
each crippled child who he looks like
from movies and men's magazines the
barbers clipping and snipping at their
dirty ropes of hair falling off the beds
onto the floor for been the porter to
sweep up the men from the barber college
sweep the beds with little brooms from
the deep pockets of their white jackets
which you all keep peering into for more
gum and there is always more gum and
from the deep pockets they pull the pint
flask of cologne and Cooling colored
water they clap on their hands and rub
around your necks and on your faces and
through your hair like a blessed baptism
that opens your lungs for the first time
and forever with its fragrance
remembering you to a world beyond that
doesn't smell like bedpans piss pants
dirty sheets the deathly perfumed stench
of yourselves rotting and rancid plaster
everyone wishes the barbers came every
week like to practice preachers but the
barbers do not the only good thing to
practice preachers bring is the
pornography the vivid picture books of
martyrs led and bound to rocks where
they will have their hands chopped off
by the Laughing scoundrels all the boys
like the picture so much the practice
preachers stop bringing them the
practice preachers can't stand how you
all laugh at the guys with the
chopped-off hands the way they sit with
their faces turned up toward the clouds
blood gushing from their bloody stumps
like broken red pipes their hangdog
tongues their mangy shoulder-length
their their eyes staring stupidly up
into heaven
your father is coming for you on a
stationwagon the head nurse says you say
goodbye to nurse Wilfong who bathes you
every day
you say goodbye to Big Mike the boy with
the melted face and you give him your
transistor radio you give your best
friend Michael Christian the black boy
and perpetual leg braces all of your
contraband an old Christmas 10 of stale
pretzels and the rubberband slingshot
metal tip balsa jets some Shriners that
hand it out and were confiscated after
everyone had shot them stuck into the
acoustic tile ceiling you give the human
skeleton a 10 medal truck a little
daredevil figure that's shot out of a
cracker jack box price cannon he breaks
it the first time he fires it you write
a note to the girl on the girls ward you
talk to on the lawn when Hogan's Heroes
came Colonel Klink telling you he had a
son named mark you tell the girl you're
sorry it's over you're going home the
young nurse who had passed all the notes
back and forth reads it and lasts and
throws it away you say goodbye to bend
the porter who always gave you a pony
blanket at nap time that didn't smell
like diarrhea and who always saved you a
little paper cup of pineapple juice when
that time was over you say goodbye to
Jerry who now doesn't have any legs at
all two hours home everything recedes
through the back station wagon window
you and your body cast on a pallet of
old blankets Richmond cigarette
factories the signs of the crater the
plank road the fields of peanut stacks
and the dark alleys of Swamp Road a man
from your father's work a man who
survived Omaha Beach when 98% of his
company did not who loses his only son
to a tiny complication in a minor
surgery helps your father lift you from
the back of the station wagon the man
from your father's work carries you like
a piece of precious furniture he is
afraid to break into your house tilting
you at the door because you're plastered
legs are cast too wide and you
momentarily
grasp the old brass knocker door knocker
each with the name of the family who had
lived there long before your family did
Livesey your father has rented a
hospital bed and pushed it against the
window of a downstairs bedroom no one
sleeps in it is Indian summer and still
hot in your house does not have air
conditioning the cotton in your cast is
hot in your legs itch and you wonder if
little things you feel down in the
plaster that you can't reach with an
unbent coat hanger or trickling sweat or
something nesting like those things he
found in the kid from Appalachia is cast
when they cut it off you know you smell
bad and sometimes your mother walks
through waving a cloud of disinfectant
spray in the air looking at the ceiling
as if that is where the smell is coming
from and not from you you don't want
visitors in your best friend David
understands this and he and his dog wolf
come and talk to you through the window
screen David as the preacher down the
streets third son of four you've been
warned away from him by the lady next
door the day you moved in he's troubled
the lady said she said you ought to play
with her son Jim when redheaded David
came around your backyard that first
afternoon to steal your moving crates
and boxes you became best friends to
this day fifty years running sometimes
walk the large blue collie sleeps in the
shrubbery under your window you can hear
his tags clink in the evenings as he
settles in he's a good dog the clinking
of his tags always calms you he has
slept there many nights the two summers
before when David came over and you two
played a Monopoly game that you made
last from Memorial Day until Labor Day
sheaves of wide rule paper documenting
the moves of phantom players the
building of triple hotels the
alternating ownership of the bank your
mother has your baby sister to tend to
and she has you and you have to teach
your mother how to bathe you how to
empty a bedpan when to bring a urinal
how to help you
flip over so she can change your sheets
your father doesn't come into your room
munch no one is happy except your baby
sister when they left turns of the
playpen of your hospital bed she crawls
all over you and sits beside your head
and laughs while she slaps your face and
you let her there are two positions in
the body cast face up and face down and
from either position you can watch your
street go by there is Auggie who lives
in the maid's house across the street he
gets up at dawn to drive by the cemetery
to check the lights at the radio tower
before driving to the little studio in
the low-end strip mall on the river to
warm up the transmitter and those days
he is the voice of the town and everyone
listens to his morning show the news of
whether the 20 year old songs the
birthdays and anniversaries the
lost-and-found the church Supper
announcements be still and know the
inspirational program with a church
organ the sports scores the gentle
chiding of the town elders when they
needed it the dedication of songs when
someone needed it the remembrances of
people who needed remembering and the
marathon fundraising in the window of
the Chevrolet dealership owned by the
man whose wife taught Sunday school and
was a member of the Hitler Youth the
fundraising for the star football player
who'd fallen from a tree retrieving a
shot squirrel and broke his back there
is a lady walking past who works it's a
telephone company petit same sweater
even in summer purse held tightly almost
to her throat her shoulders lift as she
walks as if she is always cold and
shivering every Sunday night your
parents call your mother's parents down
on Louisiana to make a long-distance
call you have to dial zero and ask an
operator for help there are only a
handful of operators and you recognize
their voices like this lady in the
sweater from down the street
who lives in the falling down house next
to the Christian Church with her four
children an older daughter who is a high
school cheerleader two twin boys who
were some
who were sometimes left at their
grandparents house while the mother
worked at the switchboard lat and a
little girl last winter when the pond
where mrs. Richardson drowned herself
froze over the two twin boys and a
friend of theirs from down on the other
side of the street took a kickball out
on the ice and they fell through
one of the twins managed to crawl ashore
and get help but by the time everybody
got there there was only the hole in the
ice where the two boys disappeared
nearby the kickball sat on the ice and
the melting Sun
they pulled the bodies out but nobody
wanted to go out any farther on the
thinning ice to get the kickball the
next day the grandfather went down there
with a shotgun and he blew the kickball
apart shooting it again and again until
it disappeared both families moved away
and the church which owned the
falling-down house tore it down and made
it into a parking lot that it is to this
day
once listening in on the extension phone
when your parents call Louisiana and the
operator is a lady who has lost her
child you can hear the sad story in her
voice even when she only says you are
connected and then your grandfather
answers the phone hello and your mother
says c'mon tsubasa and your grandfather
who misses your mother who is the eldest
daughter who is so far away and who has
lost her faith you can hear him in his
low voice that he will not be putting
your grandmother on the line as he says
pama not bad she reap a mile it - and
then you faintly hear someone crying on
the line somewhere and you don't know if
it is your mother knowing her mother has
not forgiven her or if it is a lady from
down the street listening in her
operator's mouthpiece in a tight little
fist clenched against her sweater
shivering breast and there's the blind
man passing the man who reupholstered
furniture by touch he comes tapping with
his white and red cane red lit 'add
rolled black
a half-smile and even if you hold your
breath he turns his head and looks into
your window neatly raising his right
foot to miss the place where the walnut
tree has levered up the sidewalk to trip
in him in front of your house
and there goes one of the sisters who
used to babysit you
the sisters sharing a bedroom and a
house in the next block where one night
a hand holding a screwdriver floated
into their room through the punctured
window screen between their beds when
the older sister used to babies who used
to babysit you she used to draw Moody
pencil sketches of old rowboats rotting
on chains and a cypress swamp and
there's David's father
the preacher getting into their ancient
blue station wagon pipe bitten down
himself nearly blind in one eye a large
enough man so you can hear him humming
ahem from two doors down and across the
street Lord plant my feet on higher
ground you miss the parsonage where you
spent as much time as you did in your
own house before your hips happened a
place that always smelled like bacon and
coffee the old pages and leather of
books about God and the apostles
Virginia history places in the world
where the preacher intended to travel
the preacher and his wife Janet are like
your other parents you being the fifth
brother to the four sons they already
have the preacher never holds it against
him any of you for being boys prone to
mischief even sometimes as a preacher's
Church the carillon goes off
unexpectedly during the day sometimes
broadcasting chopsticks shave and a
haircut or the four-note opening of the
twilight zone theme once one of his
elder sons rummaged through his war lute
and hung a three-story Nazi banner from
the attic window on Flag Day sending
mrs. Butler the school music teacher
into a telephone pole when she saw it
you and David goose stepping on the
front sidewalk as an elder son of C Kyle
from the attic window and later when you
and David pinned some children down and
a
ROG shootin him in their butts with
David's new BB gun
the preacher comes home to where you and
David are sitting on the porch and
quietly asked to see the new rifle that
he calmly wraps around the tree in the
front yard before going into dinner the
preacher says he did not believe in the
concept of original sin until he had
children the Saturday afternoon your
father covers your window with thick
grey plastic that mr. pant and two doors
down is cutting his grass with the
town's only electric lawnmower
it is late fall and the rye grass is
lush and the Sun is leaving early your
house is cold and drafty and your father
is stapling plastic on the window frames
he is a black shadow on the plastic
outside your window and you're glad
you're not having to hold the ladder so
he can climb to the second-story windows
because you never hold the hat ladder
just right once when he almost fell
you'd let go so he wouldn't fall on top
of you mr. panthans eyesight is poor and
he has run over the court to his
electric lawn more so many times that
the cord is forever shortened in
electrical tape splicings he can't reach
the far corners of his yard anymore you
hear mr. Penton run over his court again
in the dusk your father shadow moves off
and your gray window to the world fades
to black
the next morning will be Sunday and your
father will load you into the back of
the station wagon and take you back to
Richmond in just Dakotah about the
preacher
this is later in the author's life the
first time you are arrested it is for
assaulting a police officer your parents
and your baby sister are out of town
you're on Main Street and it is Saturday
morning before you have to go to work at
the radio station
you stand between two parked cars and
shoot into traffic with a water pistol
your best friend David comes along and
wonders what you're doing it's fun you
tell him here's some coins go into the
dime store and get a water pistol get a
big one you tell him soon he joins you
and here comes a police car you reach
out almost into their car and shoot the
police officers in the face suddenly
you're in the back of the police car
driving one block to jail the two police
officers bringing you in front of the
lieutenant you think this is funny
absolute tenant as he empties the water
pistol squirting it in your face they
put you in a Cell and slam the door they
probably already know about you stealing
lumber from behind the oil company
throwing crab apples at trucks shooting
that traveling salesman with the navy
beans through a blowgun your best friend
David makes what must be one of the
longest walks of his life to the jail to
turn himself in when he appears in the
doorway the police grab him as if he
isn't an escaped convict and throw him
into the cell with you the preacher is
writing out a sermon when he gets the
call from the police station the
preacher says he can set his watch on
Mondays after Sunday sermon by the
arrival of the delegation of little old
ladies who have a problem with something
in his sermon from the day before
sometimes the problems in the church
have been about full immersion because
they are Baptist sometimes the problems
are about an usher saying he will not
see the black person if one dares to
show up for service to the preacher the
the most problems reside in the answer
to the question do you love your
neighbor as yourself
the preachers voice out on the police
station sounds the way it does when he
gives a blessing as he greets of police
officers and soon the jailer comes to
get David it has been hard to look at
him because of what you have gotten him
into the jailer pulls David out of the
cell and then slams the door shut and
locks it not only are you going to miss
work it's a radio station this afternoon
you have begin you have to begin to
think about spending the rest of the
weekend in jail unless your parents come
home then you hear footsteps you look up
and the preacher is standing with his
pipe looking into your cell he says to
the jailer and I'll take this one the
preacher preaches that the end of pride
is the beginning of forgiveness that
when a man in sincerity says I have
sinned
it gives God a chance to say I forgive
the preacher says that he is a sinner
that his witness is that of one beggar
telling another where to find bread the
only sin you ever know him to commit is
when he sometimes drives too fast up
north High Street on his way home and
gets caught in a speed trap by the
cemetery his sin is telling the
policeman that the reason he was driving
so fast was so he could get to the
hospital before visiting hours were over
allowed on his way the preacher then
invariably drives on to the hospital to
give truth to the lie and perform little
graces of comfort as afforded by the
unwitting Police Department thank you
thank you it's just so relentlessly
ground I was telling John at suppertime
but I don't know there's moments I guess
anyway if you want to go it's 5:00 to
9:00 if you have questions and you want
to talk I'm here if you have a couple of
questions before we break i'd love to
entertain them
it's your completely your call dr.
Summerville made us read this book
already yes sir how did I choose second
person narration really good question
you know I'd not written a memoir and
when I started writing it it just when I
started saying I I is like you
sentimental SAP it's just like it just
sounded to like oh and then I had a
broken hip and then I had to go to the
hospital these bad things happen to you
know it was just like it found sounded
very claiming in a way and I thought
well the third person you - will just
write a novel you know in the second
person we talked a little about this
yesterday I think in the South you try
to if you're having to tell someone an
intimate story you really have to make
them complicit in the narrative and so I
think that it's like what you know what
I'm saying you go to this place this
happens you're not the type of person
but you know here you are and I think it
kind of I'm hoping it generates an
intimacy it couldn't have been any other
way also I wrote this book very quickly
I wrote the first section by itself I
don't know for an essay about becoming a
writer and then in my Hollywood stuff I
had to go to HBO for a pitch and I went
to this pitch and it was catastrophic
and my wife is really pissed off because
my Asian had not done due diligence and
I've wasted like three more
on this pitch that they and this is bad
when you're in it like seven minutes
into a pitch that the producer says stop
I've heard this pitch before and I look
over to you know the other guy to go
this is a remake of the BBC thing these
people were in here the other day we're
going we didn't know we were working on
the same project anyway I go home my
wife is gone that's really messed up and
she said you owe
Doubleday a book so what you're going to
do is let me pack you a duffle and then
you're going out to Palm Springs out
into the desert where there's a really
worn down Hilton and you're gonna come
back with the manuscript so I took the
first 20 pages of what this is and went
out to the Hilton for like two weeks and
I just drew the blinds and I think there
was a casino across the street so I
could eat and have some entertainment
periodically but I drew them laughs I
didn't know it was day or night coffee
cigarettes little vodka well you know
card slot machine and I found that the
headlong rush of saying you you got me
through it and so after about two weeks
you know I had this book but I look we
live with our lives in our head
especially if you have lived a life that
doesn't make total sense to you you're
going back always and looking for clues
where did I go wrong
what could I have done differently
should I've married the supermodel we
talked to you know you don't know but
I'm the type of person who's neurotic
and just keeps playing it over and over
and go like if I keep playing it on my
head it'll turn out the right way and
it's like no you're just remembering
even more bad stuff and then you put it
in the book
I didn't have but I didn't have the last
portion of the book about the the faith
and the the church and the preacher that
came from I think just paying attention
to the work and working hard I wasn't I
had no idea how this book was going to
end my original thesis for this book but
I'll make this brief I live in a place
where the nat turner insurrection
happened where a black slave led a
revolt 1836 and after he and his
followers you know killed with like 58
people like mostly unfortunately women
and children in their beds with hand
tools when they caught in that they hung
him they cut his head off
they stuck his head in the black part of
town the pike dared anyone to touch it
they boiled him into fat and then they
skinned what was left and they made
trinkets out of his skin so like and
Bible covers coin purses and I was when
I was like in fifth grade I was on
crutches having come back from this
hospital show-and-tell kid brings a
board to school two pieces of leather on
it
passes around for show-and-tell we don't
know what it is it's a piece in that
Turner's skin now I had just been in a
hospital with a lot of black kids and
you have to understand this isn't a very
racially divided South and blacks were
the other you know you're white and we
weren't really white white my father was
dark complected we're from Louisiana but
I was fascinated not fascinated but
blacks were the other but I just been in
the hospital with so many of them and
they're not they they bleed and it's not
it's we're all the same you know and the
preacher was was like that too so my
thesis of the book was I know he's got a
piece of that turner skin I know where
his skull is I know who has a piece of
my book was gonna reassemble in that
Turner I found his sword his bye focus
he was a religious prophet it wasn't a
race war to him and when I gave that
thesis to my publisher she was going
boy this is really crazy why don't you
write about growing up in this
environment rather than just itemizing
the things you found and that's kind of
what happened and then that led to the
part in the book about the black church
my family is involved with which is
House of Prayer number two so I didn't
know all that though when I went to the
desert all I had was just like no you
didn't want to be a writer he just wants
to pick up trash with the mail you know
that's all I had but I kept pushing it
and playing slots and pushing it which I
find it oddly therapeutic you know I'm
like slightly autistic to a special
child I can count the reals sometimes
you know old honest machines and they
they'll pay off yeah so but I don't want
to keep you at John it's after 9:00
so you're we can go up and do the thing
yeah yeah that sounds good thank you all
for coming out